Au sud de Madagascar,
au milieu d'un désert de roches,
Ilakaka,
Une petite ville de 40 000 habitants
à l'apparence paisible,
Comme il y en a tant sur la grande Île.
Ilakaka est pourtant célèbre dans
le monde entier pour ses petits cailloux.
Des saphirs.
Un commerce que les habitants
font en plein jour, dans la rue.
Les touristes de passage ne manquent
pas de faire une halte,
Pour y acheter des bijoux.
Tout ça, ça vient de cette région ?
On peut avoir ça avec
un petit collier aussi ?
Dans le même genre,
dans la même couleur ?
Pourtant, il y a quelques années,
les autorités,
Déconseillaient aux voyageurs de s'y arrêter.
Il y a 12 ans, cette ville était le centre
d'une ruée sans précédent.
Nous avions posé notre caméra
au cœur de ce Far West moderne.
Il y a un an et demi,
c'était un arrêt d'autobus.
Il y avait sept maisons de terre
et 85 habitants.
Aujourd'hui, c'est la capitale du Saphir.
Ilakaka était alors un bidonville dangereux,
Où les armes circulaient au grand jour.
Les acheteurs étrangers,
principalement thaïlandais,
Craignaient les attaques de bandits.
Mais une autre menace planait
sur la région.
Dans les centaines de galeries creusées
à la va vite par les Malgaches,
La mort guettait.
À chaque instant, les mineurs
pouvaient mourir ensevelis.
Ne tape pas sur les parois ni sur le plafond,
sinon ça risque de s'effondrer.
Il faut que tu creuse juste devant
toi en faisant attention.
Nous avions rencontré un trio
d'amis venu de la capitale,
Myvo, Rasta et José.
Ils avaient tout juste 20 ans.
Nous sommes à sept mètres
sous la surface.
Ils doivent d'abord sortir
cette terre, la tamiser.
Mais s'ils veulent élargir leurs
boyaux, ils vont prendre des risques.
Nous pensons que le saphir est le moyen
le plus rapide pour devenir riche.
Tous ceux qui sont venus ici
pour chercher des pierres précieuses,
En ont trouvé.
Nous savons que ce travail
est très dangereux, suicidaire.
Mais si on veut devenir riche,
alors il faut accepter de risquer sa vie.
Car ici, il n'y a pas d'argent facile.
Pour en gagner, il faut toujours
se battre avec la mort.
So, enlève l'eau parce que
ça commence à venir.
Enlève, je te dis !
Dans une carrière d'Ilakaka,
nous avons retrouvé José.
Il a aujourd'hui 33 ans.
Il prospecte toujours,
mais dans une mine à ciel ouvert.
Je travaille tous les jours,
je n'ai jamais de repos.
En 12 ans, il n'a pas fait fortune.
À l'époque,
On pensait devenir riche
comme tout le monde.
Des trois copains que nous avions filmés,
José est le seul qui soit resté à Ilakaka.
On était trois.
Les deux sont partis.
L'un est mort, l'autre s'est marié.
Rasta est mort. C'est lui qui m'avait
appris à travailler dans les mines.
Et il est tombé malade dans la carrière.
Il n'avait pas de quoi payer
les médicaments.
Il est mort de la fièvre typhoïde.
Il ne reste plus que moi ici.
Lui n'a pas d'autre choix
que de continuer ici.
J'ai pu m'acheter une petite
maison dans mon village.
Quand j'ai trouvé une pierre en 2007.
Je n'ai donc pas trop déçu ma famille.
Mais aujourd'hui, je ne gagne rien.
Il espère toujours trouver la pierre
qui le sortira de la misère,
Et lui permettra enfin de quitter la mine.
Mais il est comme prisonnier
de son rêve de fortune,
Comme des milliers de Malgaches
encore aujourd'hui à Ilakaka.
Ici, le mythe de l'argent facile
n'est pas mort.
L'ampleur du gisement a dépassé
toutes les espérances.
Mais aujourd'hui, il faut faire presque 2h
de route pour trouver les nouveaux filons.
Marc Noverraz est un négociant suisse.
C'est un des plus grands spécialistes
en pierres précieuses de la planète.
Il vit dans cette région depuis 1998,
Depuis les débuts de la ruée
vers les saphir.
On peut passer en voiture ?
Vous pouvez passer par là
et vous montez après.
On est en dessous, devant la rivière,
On va essayer de traverser puis d'aller voir
le plus grand village de mineurs,
Qu'on trouve actuellement dans la région.
Sur les bords de la rivière,
Des centaines d'ouvriers s'affairent.
Ils tamisent la terre qui a été
extraite des mines,
dans le but d'y trouver des saphirs.
Parmi eux, il y a aussi des enfants.
Le travail est toujours artisanal.
Pour éviter les vols, des hommes en armes
surveillent les opérations.
Les gens arrivent à laver
jusqu'à 2000 sacs de graviers.
Donc on peut estimer cela
à une centaine de mètres cubes.
Quand on estime qu'il y a un peu plus
d'un gramme de minéralisation par mètre cube,
Donc on imagine qui on produit 100 à 150
grammes de saphirs ici tous les jours.
Ce qui est tout de même assez
conséquent à l'échelle humaine.
Avant d'arriver aux mines, il faut encore
traverser la rivière.
Puis rouler un quart d'heure
sur cette piste.
Nous allons découvrir que les conditions
de travail demeurent effroyables.
Là, on est sur les hauteurs de la rivière,
donc en plein cœur du gisement.
C'est toujours le même principe
qu'il y a dix ans.
Ce système de puits existe depuis toujours.
Je pense simplement que c'est mieux
organisé avec des systèmes d'étayage,
Et des systèmes de tirfor
qui permettent de remonter.
Aujourd'hui les Malgaches on vraiment
l'expérience de l'exploitation et du gisement.
- Il y a des gens en dessous ?
- Oui.
À combien de mètres est le filon ?
Ça fait à peu près 30 mètres.
Solo a 27 ans.
Sept jours sur sept,
il descend au fond du puits.
Son salaire, 1,80€ par jour.
C'est difficile d'aller sous terre
parce que c'est très profond.
30 mètres au lieu de 5 à 8 en 2000.
Pourtant, cette mine n'est pas
la plus profonde.
Ici, certains puits descendent
à plus de 50 mètres sous terre.
Chaque jour Solo y descend
en s'accrochant au sac,
Qui sert aussi à remonter le minerai.
Plus il s'enfonce dans le boyau,
plus la chaleur devient étouffante.
Il faut une autre planche
pour maintenir le plafond.
Tu vas réussir à remplir plusieurs sacs ?
C'est très difficile de respirer
à l'intérieur.
On a si peu de place, on n'est pas à l'aise,
on manque toujours d'air.
Ça devient très dur là-dedans.
Pour leur fournir un peu d'oxygène,
Les Malgaches ont inventé un système
d'aération artisanal.
Ils envoient de l'air via ce tuyau
bricolé avec du plastique.
À la surface, un ouvrier l'alimente
avec un simple sac poubelle.
Si je ne fais pas ça,
les gens en dessous étouffent.
Il y a plein de gaz en dessous.
les mineurs peuvent mourir.
Ils finissent le travail à mains nues,
Avant de ramper vers la sortie.
Traînant derrière eux un sac
de 30 kilos de terre.
En 2000, chaque semaine,
quatre prospecteurs mouraient ensevelis.
Depuis que ces galeries ont été
renforcées par du bois,
Il y a moins de morts dans les mines.
Mais le danger est toujours là.
Bien sûr que j'ai peur d'avoir un accident,
Mais il faut bien que
je gagne de l'argent.
J'ai envie de vivre mieux.
Si je prends de tels risques,
c'est pour devenir riche,
Et avoir un beau 4x4
comme certains en ont.
La richesse, la vie meilleure,
Ils étaient déjà des milliers
à y croire en 2000.
La fièvre du saphir n'épargnait personne,
pas même les enfants.
Nous avions rencontré Ferdinand.
Ferdinand a dix ans.
Lui est né ici.
Un des 85 habitants d'avant la ruée.
Avant, il faisait le guide pour les rares
touristes qui s'arrêtaient sur la nationale.
Un débrouillard.
Si tu fais le guide, c'est 25 000.
Alors si tu achètes les Saphir ici
à 40 000 balles, tu vends à 250...
Et c'est une chance pour moi.
Je suis très content.
Le garçon c'était improvisé intermédiaire
entre les prospecteurs et les acheteurs étrangers.
Il avait même quelques rabatteurs
qui travaillaient pour lui.
Ferdinand a vite appris.
Ni lampe, ni loupe et pourtant,
Il remarque tout de suite
la pierre intéressante.
Venez ! Il y a trop de curieux ici !
Je ne veux pas sortir mon fric ici.
Il y a quelques jours, Ferdinand s'est
retrouvé avec un pistolet sur la tempe.
L'homme est parti avec tout son argent.
Il essaie, depuis, de faire attention.
Ce jour là, c'est à un acheteur suisse
que Ferdinand avait revendu le saphir.
200 000, ce qu'il avait acheté
40 000 à peine dix minutes plus tôt,
200 000 francs malgaches.
Le salaire mensuel d'un ouvrier à Madagascar.
Avec cet argent, le petit Ferdinand
faisait vivre sa famille.
Sa mère et quatre frères et sœurs.
Ils s'entassaient
dans cette maison minuscule.
Une pièce au confort rudimentaire.
Douze ans plus tard,
nous avons retrouvé Ferdinand.
Il a bien changé.
Dans le centre ville d'Ilakaka,
Il commence par nous rejouer
la scène du négociateur averti.
- Combien celle là ?
- 180€.
Je t'en donne 50 centimes.
Tu te fous de moi ou quoi ?
Rends-moi ma pierre.
- Alors combien ?
- Non, je ne te la vends pas.
- 1€ alors ?
- T'es pas sérieux ?
Je ne la vends pas.
- Comment ce n'est pas à vendre ?
- Non, ton prix est trop bas.
Nous allons vite comprendre que Ferdinand
a honte de nous avouer la vérité.
Son petit commerce a échoué.
Je te la fais à 60€.
- 8€ ?
- Jamais.
Il vaut mieux que j'aille
chercher ailleurs alors !
Oui, c'est ça ! Bon voyage.
Cela fait bien longtemps
qu'il n'a plus rien acheté.
En ce moment, je ne gagne pas
beaucoup de pierres...
- Donc c'est ta maman qui te nourrit ?
- Oui.
Pour lui, comme pour tant d'autres
dans la région,
Le saphir n'aura été qu'un mirage.
Ferdinand vit aujourd'hui chez sa mère.
Il a déçu les espoirs de sa famille.
Quand auras-tu de l'argent
pour qu'on achète de la viande ?
Ça dépend si je découvre
la pierre bleue ou pas.
On attend une pierre pour
manger de la viande ?
Oui, il faut attendre le saphir.
Il mange beaucoup celui-là !
C'est que j'ai faim.
Attends d'avoir de l'argent et tu pourras
penser à t'acheter à manger.
J'ai aussi plein de problèmes
avec ma femme.
On est séparés et elle ne veut
pas me donner mon fils.
Elle me le laissera seulement
si je paye deux zébus.
Vous savez, c'est la coutume ici.
Il me faut absolument 300€
pour espérer revoir mon enfant.
En pensant faire fortune avec les saphirs,
Ferdinand n'a pas jugé bon d'aller à l'école.
Il ne sait ni lire ni écrire.
Le jeune homme est à la dérive.
J'ai rêvé.
J'étais si sûre de gagner beaucoup.
Malheureusement, ça n'a absolument
pas été le cas.
En 2000, nous avions rencontré
un autre enfant.
La petite fiancée de Ferdinand.
Ferdinand a une petite amie.
Elle a douze ans et s'appelle Olga.
Leurs relations sont parfois
empreintes de quelques tensions.
Voilà quelques jours qu'Olga lui demande
de lui offrir une paire de chaussures.
Olga aussi gagne de l'argent.
Mais son commerce à elle
est d'une autre nature.
Qu'est-ce qu'elle fait dans la vie,
cette petite fille ?
Elle va avec les garçons.
La fille ? Avec quel garçon ?
Les Thaïlandais ?
Oui, Thaïlandais et Malgaches.
- Quel âge as-tu ?
- 15 ans.
Olga ment, elle n'a que douze ans.
Enlèves ta casquette,
qu'on admire ton minois.
Enlève ta casquette !
Tous les jours, Olga subissait
les moqueries des travailleurs malgaches.
À l'époque, les petites prostituées
n'étaient pas rares.
Les enfants comme Olga
travaillaient au grand jour.
Une situation révolue aujourd'hui.
Un an après notre tournage,
Olga a déménagé.
Ferdinand ne l'a jamais revu.
Pour nous, il a retrouvé sa piste à Tuléar,
À 300 kilomètres au sud d'Ilakaka.
Il n'a pas son adresse précise.
Bonjour, je voulais savoir si vous
connaissiez cette personne.
Oui, je la connais.
- Où est-ce que je peux la trouver ?
- Elle est dans la cour.
Olga.
Tu sais Ferdinand,
mon vrai prénom c'est Eva.
Cela fait treize ans
qu'on ne s'est pas vus.
Tu es un homme maintenant.
Je suis tellement contente
de tout mon cœur, vraiment.
Je croyais que tu m'avais oublié,
ça fait si longtemps.
Aujourd'hui, Olga a 24 ans.
Elle nous reçoit chez une voisine,
Car elle a honte de nous montrer
le grand dénuement dans lequel elle vit.
Elle aussi a un enfant,
Une petite fille de quatre ans
qu'elle tient à présenter à Ferdinand.
Où est son père ?
Son père a disparu quand j'étais enceinte.
J'étais avec un Blanc.
Il a tout fait pour m'avoir.
Il m'a donné à manger,
Il m'a donné de l'argent.
J'ai finalement accepté,
et maintenant je suis pauvre.
Il m'a dit qu'il allait à Tana
et qu'il reviendrait.
Mais je ne l'ai jamais revu.
Olga continue à se prostituer.
Je sors avec ceux
qui me donnent de l'argent.
Il faut que je puisse survivre
et que je nourrisse ma fille.
J'attends les hommes au coin de la rue.
Quand ils me donnent 80 centimes d'euros
par passe.
En 1 mois, j'arrive à gagner 10€.
Nous lui avons montré les images
de notre premier reportage,
De cette époque où les humiliations
étaient quotidiennes.
Etrangement, elle éprouve de la nostalgie.
Je m'en souviens.
C'est ce que j'ai le plus aimé
dans ma vie, avoir des poupées.
Je regrette ma vie d'avant.
On avait un peu d'argent, mais maintenant,
on n'a plus rien du tout.
Je regrette tellement ma vie d'avant.
Olga, Ferdinand,
N'étaient que des gamins à l'époque
de la ruée vers les saphirs.
Eux n'y ont rien gagné, bien au contraire.
En 2000, nous avions rencontré un
prospecteur qui avait fait fortune.
Gaspard était le propriétaire de cette
grande carrière baptisée la Banque suisse.
L'unique Malgache à exploiter
un filon de manière industrielle.
Son succès alimentait les rêves
de toute une génération de mineurs.
Des pierres, il en a beaucoup trouvé.
En moyenne pour 20 millions
de francs malgaches par mois.
Et plus il creuse, plus il en trouve.
Tous les matins,
il vide l'eau du trou,
Qui s'est rempli la nuit.
Prenez ces planches et clouez-les au poteau.
Gaspard a les moyens.
Beaucoup de ceux qui sont venus
au début ont eu de la chance.
Lui n'a jamais creusé car dès son arrivée,
il a fait une superbe affaire.
La première fois que j'ai eu
une pierre comme ça,
Je l'ai acheté à 7500 francs,
Et je l'ai vendu aux Thaïlandais 5 millions.
Je me suis dit :
"Là, je commence à avoir de l'argent."
666 fois la mise.
Et des affaires comme celles-là,
il en a fait d'autres.
Il y a un an et demi,
Gaspard a interrompu ses études.
Grâce au saphir, il s'est
acheté une maison à Tuléar,
Sa ville natale et cinq taxis.
Il sait que les pierres précieuses
ne seront pas éternelles.
En tous les cas,
il a besoin de respectabilité.
Il me faut dans la vie un double emploi.
Je pense faire l'Ecole
normale d'administration.
Il rêvait de devenir haut fonctionnaire,
directeur ou préfet.
C'est à Tuléar, la grande ville du sud,
que nous l'avons retrouvé.
Il y a huit ans, il a fait faillite
et a dû abandonner la banque suisse.
Gaspard est bien devenu fonctionnaire,
Mais il est seulement chef de service
au ministère de l'Agriculture.
Bonjour, je viens vous remettre mon rapport.
Je vais en prendre connaissance,
Mais sachez que vous aurez aussi
une présentation à faire.
J'ai raté le concours d'administration parce
que j'ai fait du saphir pendant 3, 4 ans.
Je n'ai pas fait de révision,
je n'ai rien dans la tête.
Madeleine, sa supérieure hiérarchique,
connaît son passé.
Je ne le réprime pas d'avoir
tenté un peu l'aventure dans le saphir,
Mais rester jusqu'à la fin de ses jours
dans le saphir, c'est vraiment difficile à croire.
Gaspard a pris des risques.
Il a tout perdu, sauf cette maison
achetée grâce à l'argent du saphir.
Avec sa famille, il vit modestement.
Sa femme a dû, elle aussi,
se mettre au travail.
Pourtant, c'est sans état d'âme que Gaspard
évoque la fin de son aventure dans les mines.
Je suis parti d'Ilakaka en 2003,
Puisque j'ai perdu beaucoup d'argent.
J'ai dépensé mon argent
en faisant des carrières,
J'ai payé des ouvriers miniers,
Et des carburants.
On attend 1, 2 mois
pour trouver des saphirs.
C'est ça qui...
Qui a provoqué ma perte.
On est allé à Ilakaka en pensant
devenir millionnaire,
Milliardaire même !
Malheureusement, l'argent ne fait que passer.
Je n'ai pas de regrets.
Là-bas c'était, comment dire ?
Diabolique.
Les gens ne faisaient que la fête,
Ils croyaient que c'était la belle vie.
On essaie de ne plus penser
à tout ça, au saphir,
On espère plus rien des pierres.
Si Gaspard n'a pas réussi dans les saphirs,
Il a découvert une autre richesse.
La vie de famille.
Désormais, il trouve le temps
de partir avec eux en vacances.
Dans le Saphir, il n'y a pas de vacances,
Puisqu'on a toujours dans l'idée
de gagner de l'argent.
On n'ose pas quitter le saphir.
Au temps du saphir, j'avais de l'argent,
mais je n'avais pas de temps.
Mais maintenant, j'ai du temps,
Je suis heureux et je suis content
de voyager avec ma famille.
De tous ceux que nous avions
rencontrés en 2000,
Gaspard est le seul à s'être libéré
de l'emprise du saphir.
Les Malgaches ne sont pas
les grands gagnants de ce boom.
Dès les premières heures,
les étrangers se sont emparés du marché.
En 2000, quand le plus gros négociant
de la région venait faire des achats,
Il s'entourait de précautions maximales.
Bonjour tout le monde.
Werner **** est Suisse.
Il a été attaqué une fois,
c'était en Tanzanie.
On lui avait volé 500 000 francs.
Depuis, il se méfie.
Vous avez toujours un comité d'accueil
comme ça ?
Oui, c'est une région dangereuse.
Toutes les semaines il y a des attaques
contre les Thaïlandais, les Sri lankais,
les acheteurs de pierres.
Werner amène du cash.
À chaque voyage 800 000 francs français,
une fortune ici.
Les sept kilomètres qui séparent l'aéroport
de la ville, sont les plus dangereux.
C'est là que les acheteurs s'installent,
Et que les prospecteurs viennent tenter
de vendre leurs trouvailles.
Ils ont tous entendu l'avion de Werner.
C'est un bon acheteur.
Même les petites pièces l'intéressent.
Les mineurs se battaient
pour lui vendre leur pierre.
En peu de temps, Werner,
en achetait un maximum.
Les Malgaches ignoraient alors leur valeur.
Abusant de la naïveté des prospecteurs,
Aux premières heures de la ruée
vers les saphirs,
Il a gagné beaucoup d'argent.
Cela fait bien longtemps
qu'il ne vient plus à Madagascar.
Aujourd'hui, les négociants étrangers
dominent toujours le marché.
Ils ne viennent plus en avion.
La plupart vit sur place.
La quasi totalité des mines du négoce
est détenue par les Sri-Lankais, à 80%.
Ils n'aiment pas trop parler de leur affaire.
- Est-ce que c'est un bon endroit ici ?
- Oui, c'est un bon endroit ici.
Pourquoi?
Il y a des saphirs dans beaucoup d'endroits.
Pour en savoir plus sur
les coulisses de ce business,
Nous sommes retournés voir Marc Noverraz.
Lui aussi vit ici depuis 14 ans.
Il a appris le malgache.
Il est 7h du matin.
Comme chaque jour,
Marc s'installe à la fenêtre de son magasin
pour acheter des pierres.
L'ambiance est loin de la frénésie d'avant.
C'est combien ?
Je te la fais à 450€.
25€.
450€.
- Dis moi combien alors ?
- 300€.
35€.
Non, ça n'ira pas.
Il va demander 50 fois la valeur
qu'il en veut réellement,
Donc ça va faire l'objet d'une négociation,
Et c'est finalement à l'acheteur
de donner son offre.
En général, je ne donne qu'un prix,
si la pierre est vendu, tant mieux.
30€.
Non 25.
Ok, je reviens.
Marc cherche la belle pierre,
Celle qu'il pourra vendre
aux plus grands joailliers.
Ce ne sera pas pour aujourd'hui.
On réessaiera ce soir de racheter
quelques pierres,
Parce que là, apparemment,
il n'y a plus grand chose.
Il en a tout de même acheté six,
De qualité moyenne pour 130€.
Du moment où on a au moins une pierre,
on va considérer qu'on a quelque chose,
Mais on attend quand même
des jours meilleurs,
Avec des pierres plus importantes
ou de plus grande valeur.
On va dire qu'ici,
il n'y a pas vraiment de rareté.
Il faudra faire un assemblage avec plusieurs
pierres pour pouvoir les mettre en valeur.
Ce sont des pierres, j'espère,
qu'une fois taillées,
On pourra vendre le double.
Quand il ne peut pas exporter ces saphirs,
Il les vend aux touristes de passage.
Avec Philippe, son associé français,
Il a embauché trois Malgaches
pour fabriquer des bijoux sur place.
On lui apporte une valeur ajoutée,
Et on le rend vendable.
Donc nous, quand on a une pierre comme ça,
ce qu'on va chercher à faire,
c'est épouser la forme du brut
pour garder un maximum de poids.
On va les polir pour qu'elles aient
un aspect brillant comme du verre.
Ces artisans malgaches ont tous
été formés par Marc.
Ils sont précis et aussi compétents
que les tailleurs suisses.
Il leur faudra plus de 3h pour ciseler
une des pierres achetée ce jour là.
Elle sera vendue 120€ dans son magasin.
Marc a tenu à nous emmener là
où tout a commencé,
À la sortie de la ville,
La première mine d'Ilakaka,
celle de Gaspard.
La banque suisse.
On arrive sur la banque suisse.
Une des premières mines travaillait à Ilakaka.
Qui correspond à l'ancien lit
de la rivière Ilakaka.
Une gigantesque carrière à ciel ouvert,
Désormais propriété
de l'entrepreneur Sri lankais.
Aujourd'hui, il faut creuser à plus
de 50 mètres de profondeur,
Pour trouver des saphirs.
Tout ce qui était en surface, tout ce qui
était facile d'accès a été ramassé.
Je pense que d'ici une année ou deux,
tout sera terminé ici,
On aura tout travaillé.
En attendant la fin du saphir,
À Ilakaka, la bonne fortune d'un tout
petit nombre continue de faire rêver.
Mais pour beaucoup,
l'ancienne ville champignon,
Posée au milieu du désert,
N'aura été qu'un mirage.